[Musique]
ça me détend quand je pascual ou moins
je les regarde ses oeuvres je trouve ça
un peu gros un peu trop c'est trop beau
trop figuratif 3 représentatif seuil est
un peu la ville qui est un peu
tristounettes quand même quoi j'ai vu la
même chose en belgique où il y avait des
oeuvres comme ça dans les rues et il ya
déjà dix ans et je me disais pas c'est
une bonne idée
les sculptures en terre cuite de noni
mondineu sagement installés rue le nôtre
à montigny font réfléchir nos
contemporains la semaine dernière
l'artiste a inauguré l'ensemble après
trois ans de travail le thème
l'intérieur à l'extérieur
il fallait penser à faire des touches de
lumière des volumes et pour pouvoir
planter des dé faire des espaces verts
des arbres des pour animer cette fête
rue quand ils rentrent de leur travail
le fait de passer la sa des acides
peut-être à oublier le trajet en métro
qui viennent de faire et se dire tiens
je me mettrais bien dans mon canapé
les habitants s'y sentent d'ailleurs
tellement bien qu'ils n'ont pas hésité à
s'approprier cette oeuvre d'art devenu
public
les graphiques qui y ont fleuri
[Musique]